I stand here after a lifetime of education and inspiration through sport.
When I was a teenager, it was sport that opened my eyes to the world.
When I became an Olympian, it was sport that taught me about competing at the very highest level...
...in a unique spirit, making enduring friendships, including with many of you.
And in the last two years, sports has shown me time and again how it can connect and inspire,...
...from the visits of Mami Sato and others to the smiling volunteers of 2012 London...
...and the massive crowd for the athletes' parade in Tokyo.
I am lucky, so lucky, to have seen great athletes, inspiring performances...
...and the Olympic values made real.
My goal and that of my entire team is to do everything we can to promote sport,...
...faithful to the Olympic values, to as many people as possible in this challenging era.
In my travels in support of this bid, I have spoken with many of you about the issues we face.
And I'm optimistic that our shared desire to move forward together...
...will safeguard sports for new generations.
Mr. President, dear friends, that journey starts here in Buenos Aires.
These next few days will help set the course of the movement for many years to come.
Which is why there is a huge responsibility to make crucial decisions...
...for the right reason: the benefit of global sport.
Our case today is simple.
Vote for Tokyo and you vote for guaranteed delivery.
Vote for Tokyo and you vote for the superb games experience in every possible sense.
Vote for Tokyo and you vote for the global vision to benefit sport from today to 2020...
...and the many decades afterwards.
Tokyo is the right partner at the right time.
A city that will deliver,...
...a nation that shares and upholds Olympic values,...
...and the people who will work tirelessly with you in support of those precious values.
Today, on behalf of my team and all Japan, I am proud to submit our bid.
And also to give you my personal guarantee that Tokyo 2020 will see major legacies delivered,...
...massive opportunities realized...
...and sport, the Olympic movement itself, as the biggest winner!
Mr. President, this concludes our presentation.
Thank you.